[Música]
ofereço essa fala aos alunos nos amigos
professores da escola ao brasil
lá em suzano são paulo uma pergunta
central nas sociedades complexas nas
sociedades plurais é a seguinte pergunta
o que fazer com o diferente o que fazer
com aquela pessoa que pensa que age de
um modo diferente que o meu eu elimino
eu ignoro eu acolho eu faço que com essa
pessoa
por um lado nós não podemos cair no
extremo de achar que é todo mundo gente
boa aliás todo mundo é legal enquanto
não contradiz você todo mundo é amável
de longe é fácil a má amar a humanidade
não conceito abstrato difícil é mas
pessoas de carne e osso do nosso lado
por um lado não adianta fingir que está
tudo bem na realidade está aí
existem pessoas que entra em conflito
com o nosso interesse mas por outro lado
também não adianta entrar nos impor dias
sociais
não adianta apenas me cercar de tudo
aquilo que me agrada de tudo aquilo que
eu concordo de todas as narrativas
idéias conceitos e pressuposições que eu
concordo com ela senão fico na minha
bolha social e aí fica parecendo que
tudo só gira em torno de mim do meu
gosto do meu jeito mas estudei me formei
aqui na puc minas
eu não esqueço o dia que eu andei aqui
no estacionamento e tinha um adesivo
atrás de um carro que o jovem aluna que
colocou assim eu me amo e diversa é o
que muitas pessoas pensam né a pessoa
pensa que tudo é pra ela só por causa
dela eu me lembro né é decidir que eu
passei aqui os meninos esvaziar o pneu
não precisa chegar a esse ponto é não
precisa chegar não vai resolve sozinho
mas muitas vezes nós agimos assim já
acorda de manhã
a rede social e coloca lá e sentindo
triste
ninguém perguntou a menor informação que
muda precisando e você tem essa
necessidade de ficar falando da minha
família meu sogro roberto ea minha sogra
disse tem uma história muito famosa
nossa família quando eles eram jovens é
o meu sogro levou minha sogra pra um
jantar especial assim no restaurante e
ele ficou aflito que tinha um sujeito do
lado de olho na minha sogra disse ele
começou a perder a fome falou disso
aquele cargo naquela mesa não tira o
olho de você e minha sogra
segundo roberta bonita mesmo pessoal ea
minha é assim que você olha eu tô
perdendo a fome ele começou a brigar com
ela ele começou a brigar com ela ou eu
to indo embora nesse restaurante ao
ponto de lhe chamar o garçom aquele
conhecido falava assim arquivar só eu
estou aqui tentando jantar com a minha
namorada minha noiva que sujeita mesmo
tira o olho daqui
o garçom falou com meu sogro assim
roberto desde besteira isso aquele cara
lá sempre vem aqui ele nem tem os olhos
ele nem olho tem como é que ele vai
olhar para a sua para sua mulher aí ele
não enxerga e você tá aí com os ciúmes
é isso que acontece muitas vezes quando
nós estamos tem boi atos em nós mesmos
que todo gira em torno do que nós
achamos e os nossos achismos vão se
tornando então ilusões que a gente pensa
trata como se fosse realidade o que é
uma guerra
o que é uma guerra senão o choque de
bolhas o que é uma guerra senão a
vitória da intransigência o triunfo da
incomunicabilidade as pessoas não
quererem conversar mais essa é a foto da
can porque punk
aos nove anos de idade no vietnã todo
mundo já viu essa foto tirada no dia 8
de junho de 1972 e acabou de ser atacada
por napalm com as costas que lhe manda
ela estava vestida mas a roupa dela já
tinha sido queimada a casa dela já tinha
sido queimado em madri ela sai correndo
então e essa foto ganhou no ano no dia o
grêmio no ano de pleno padeceu de melhor
foto etc
jovem ficou 14 meses internada ela
passou por 17 cirurgias depois cresceu
com muitas dores fez o seu curso de
medicina se casou e hoje mora no canadá
eu tiver alegria honra de conhecê lá no
final do ano passado em são paulo
estamos desenvolvendo trabalhos
humanitários
estive na fronteira do brasil com a
venezuela ajudando ali a proteção de
tribos que corre o risco do et no sítio
simplesmente desaparecerem de fome
estivemos em questões de segurança
hídrica no piauí
estivemos lá com os pais no realengo que
perderam seus filhos há oito anos atrás
aquela terrível chacina estivemos lá
agora há nem um mês atrás
no dia 13 e 14 de março de 2019 no
sepultamento daqueles jovens em suzano
seja como capelão batista seja com o
embaixador pela criança brasileira pela
ong visão mundial seja apoiando alguns
dos trabalhos da cno o alto comissariado
da onu pelas questões dos refugiados e
conheci lá então aqui e ela me disse
algo que mudou minha vida porque ela
falou assim quando eu cheguei no canadá
eu fui reconhecido um dia na rua e eu
tentava fugir daquilo que tinha
acontecido comigo apesar de ter as
marcas mas ela disse assim eu entendi
que não podia mudar o que eu vivi mas eu
podia mudar a maneira que aquilo me
afetava e ela se tornou então uma
embaixadora da boa vontade da onu e hoje
ela ajuda a outras crianças vítimas de
queimaduras vítima vitimados pelas
guerras ao redor do mundo com essa
simples história
nós olhamos em volta então probrasil
brasil país com maior número de
assassinatos do mundo
são 60 mil pessoas que são assassinadas
no brasil os dados de diversas
organizações de monitoramento anos
monitoram a violência brasil morre mais
gente assassinado estados unidos a china
a europa inteira ea rússia juntas então
nós estamos num verdadeiro fratricídio
no brasil já disse isso
nós deveríamos ser uma fraternidade só
esse início de ano
uma crise atrás da outra por uma dinha
que o religiosas lá no flamengo que
morreram agora chuva é tanta tragédia ao
invés das pessoas se unirem falarem pela
paz manifestações pelas pela paz pela
convivência acontece justamente o
contrário
parece que as bolhas sociais ficam ainda
piores queridos precisamos reaprender a
conversar e conversar significa ficar às
voltas com é ficar junto com o outro nós
precisamos uns dos outros
o fanático já dizia amós oz é aquele que
só sabe contar até um é aquela pessoa
que só pensa nele chega vamos sair das
nossas coisas
nós precisamos uns dos outros a
autonomia é desejável mas a autonomia
não é a auto suficiência nós precisamos
uns dos outros liberdade não fazer o que
eu quero não fazer o que tenho na minha
cabeça
liberdade é a capacidade de criar juntos
só é livre quem tem a capacidade de
criar juntos liberdade é a capacidade de
co criar muito obrigado
[Aplausos]